[Music]
a traveler
comes upon the statue of an emperor
inscribed with the words my name is
azamendius king of kings
look upon my works and despair
only there's nothing left beside it
except
empty desert
it is good to be back i really wish
they'd let us play music up here why
because we'd already be on our feet
ready for action we have considered your
request for passage through our
territory and we will not stop you but
do not expect us to save you
pursuing exploration always carries risk
i say we risk it everything forbidden is
sweet
this is a good day it is a good day
you do know where you're going right
nope oh boy
let's go make some history i didn't
prepare anything just speak from your
heart
we're about to enter unexplored space i
know you're all just as excited as i am
so let's give this everything we got and
may the force be with you
how was that perfect
we've served together
we'd laugh together and we all owe each
other our lives you will surrender or
you will die
and it's a very special thing we should
all get big bonuses this is
history in the making
here's to a better future i will be sure
to bring my what does lieutenant malloy
call it
my a-game there you go buddy
have to find a way to preserve some kind
of peace
humans have a tendency to reduce things
to black and white good and evil
we can find a way to coexist you're
kaylon your people would like to see us
all dead
after all these years you're still able
to surprise me show the galaxy that
humans are different that we value life
even when our enemies don't
captain you are being deceived
[Music]
it's almost like yesterday was one life
and today's
another and everything's different on
this side of time
[Music]
definitely worth the wait
[Music]
[Music]
foreign